ALEC FOSTER: Welcome to the
ClickHole talks at Google.
My name is Alec
Foster, and I'm very
pleased to welcome our
honorable guests, the founding
editors of ClickHole, Jermaine
Affonso and Ben Berkley.
Without any further ado,
let's give them a warm,
Google-y here's to you.
From us, here's to you.
BEN BERKLEY: Hello.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Hello.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for that.
We're thrilled to be here.
We're so excited to
be here at Google.
BEN BERKLEY: Yes.
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
My name is Jermaine.
BEN BERKLEY: And I'm Ben.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: And we're the
founding editors of ClickHole,
like Alec said.
And we're really just
so excited to be here.
We're pumped.
BEN BERKLEY: So, so, so excited.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: We
wanted to put together
something really special for
you guys and I hope we have.
I think this is really good.
BEN BERKLEY: I think so.
I think so.
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
But just in case, we
set up a little e-mail
address for feedback.
So this is just for you guys.
BEN BERKLEY: Yes,
please, please, please
take advantage of this great
service we're providing you.
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
ClickHoleGoogleT
alkFeedback@yahoo.com.
We just want you guys,
whatever thoughts you have,
whether it's positive, negative,
we'd love to hear any of it.
You can send them
after this, fine.
But I think in about
10, 15 minutes or so.
I think we want
to check into that
and just look to see what
you guys are saying, what
you guys are thinking,
sort of incorporate that
into the presentation.
BEN BERKLEY: We
want to put together
the best possible
presentation for you.
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
For you Googlers.
BEN BERKLEY: Yes.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: So yeah,
without further ado, I think--
BEN BERKLEY: Let's jump in.
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
Jump right into this.
So I don't know how many of
you guys are familiar with us,
or really--
BEN BERKLEY: I am.
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
You know what we do.
Great.
So yeah, let's show some
of the stuff that we do.
BEN BERKLEY: Yeah, so
here's a thing that we do.
"Heartwarming!
This fraternity
brother came out as gay
and was still just as
much of an asshole."
[LAUGHTER] This is
such an inspiring tale.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Yeah,
he's still just so much
of a dickhead.
And it's just nice.
It's great.
It's feel good story.
BEN BERKLEY: He's so brave.
And we've also done
things like, "Awesome!
This lucky school
got two proms."
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Two proms.
What could be better?
Across the city from each other.
It's great.
So great.
BEN BERKLEY: So much fun.
Both sides had a lot of fun.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Yeah.
BEN BERKLEY: And "5
Disney princesses
reimagined as Caucasian."
JERMAINE AFFONSO: We like to do
things little inspiring things
for little white girls
that are out there, just
to let them know that they
can do anything they want.
BEN BERKLEY: You can do it.
They got this.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: So
that's what this is.
BEN BERKLEY: But the real thing
we want to talk about here
is I guess, at this point,
is why are we even here?
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
Yeah, why are we here?
BEN BERKLEY: There it is.
The big question.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: So
the way this started
actually was that we received
a letter in our office
from Google, which
was really exciting.
BEN BERKLEY: Amazing.
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
It was exciting.
We got to see Google letterhead.
We were pumped.
And we actually have
the letter here just
to kind of reveal
the why exactly.
We're going to read it
out loud for you guys.
BEN BERKLEY: Also the letterhead
is gorgeous, you guys.
It's so good.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: I
love the new logo.
BEN BERKLEY: Yes.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: All
right, so here's the letter.
"Dear ClickHole, This is
Sergey Brin and Larry Page,
two men who found Google.com.
We are writing this letter
from our company's latest
innovation, a bicycle
that can write letters
and knows the date
the pope will die.
Today we are writing you
because Google needs your help.
Every day our researchers
are innovating technologies
as varied as little
doodles and automobiles
that despise humanity.
But even still,
there is one question
we've never been able to answer.
Viral content.
How?
For over 10 years, we locked
researchers in a room,
having them shriek things
at each other like, content
going viral.
Why?
Please content viral.
And the reason for viral
content, we need to know it.
And we've yielded no results.
Even now, Google has over
12 intelligent employees,
and we're all clueless.
This is why we're inviting
you, ClickHole, to come
to our lavish California
prison to tell us
how and why viral content.
We need this.
We need you.
Love, Sergey and Larry."
BEN BERKLEY: That's so exciting.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: It
was really exciting.
It warmed our hearts.
And we decided to come out here
and answer the big question.
BEN BERKLEY: Yes.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: The
massive question of our age.
BEN BERKLEY: Which
is how viral content?
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
How viral content?
BEN BERKLEY: How?
JERMAINE AFFONSO: And now we are
going to answer that for you.
BEN BERKLEY: Yes.
We've got some steps.
We've figured it out.
We know how to do it.
You're going to know
how to do it, too.
So the first step is
go on the internet.
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
Go on the internet.
BEN BERKLEY: Pretty simple.
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
But the question
is, what is the internet?
BEN BERKLEY: How do you find it?
What does it look like?
JERMAINE AFFONSO: What
does it look like?
BEN BERKLEY: This
is the internet.
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
That's the internet.
BEN BERKLEY: OK, step two.
Familiarize yourself with
what's popular online.
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
You're going to want
to know the big sites, all
the big sites of today.
BEN BERKLEY: But Jermaine,
what are the big sites?
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Well,
we did a lot of research.
BEN BERKLEY: Yes.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Here are
the big sites to share.
BEN BERKLEY: OK.
We've got Amazon.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Amazon.com.
Go on there.
You can get anything you
want mailed right to you.
BEN BERKLEY: Any time of day.
It's incredible.
All right.
Facebook.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Facebook.
Connect to your friends and
family, all day any day.
BEN BERKLEY: So cool.
So, so, so cool.
Bing.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Bing is great.
BEN BERKLEY: Yeah.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: If you
have a question, anything
you want to look
up, you can connect
to all these other sites.
It's amazing.
BEN BERKLEY: The world
is at your fingertips.
And there's another one, which--
JERMAINE AFFONSO: I
forgot what it was.
What was it?
BEN BERKLEY: LinkedIn.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: LinkedIn.
BEN BERKLEY: Wow.
Those are the sites.
Those the only big sites.
OK.
Step three.
Identifying internet content.
So it can be really confusing
out there, the dividing line.
What is internet content?
What is it maybe not?
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Yeah.
We put together a very
handy little rubric for you.
BEN BERKLEY: Yes.
Let's run this test.
So is this internet content?
Jermaine, what do you think?
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
I don't think so.
BEN BERKLEY: I think
you are correct.
It is not.
It is a fish on a plate.
This right here?
JERMAINE AFFONSO: No.
BEN BERKLEY: Human woman.
You are correct.
How about this?
JERMAINE AFFONSO: All right.
Seven sloths who are
almost too adorable
to be thrown off the top
of the Chrysler Building.
BEN BERKLEY: You got this.
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
That's content.
BEN BERKLEY: You got it.
Yes.
Content.
So now you know it.
That's huge.
All right, step four.
You're going to want to call
the internet's best friend,
see if he thinks the internet
will like the content
that you're sharing.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Well, who
is the internet's best friend?
Well, the internet's best
friend is actually Gabe.
BEN BERKLEY: Yeah, so
they're best friends.
They went to high
school together.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Yeah, they
were in the same prom group.
BEN BERKLEY: Yeah, they
went to Benihana for dinner.
Really great.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Yeah,
so you can contact him.
BEN BERKLEY: Lifelong friends.
Step five.
You're going to want to
remember all those steps.
If you don't remember the
steps, you can't do them.
So let's recap.
So step one was go
on the internet.
Step two know what's
popular online.
Step three is to identify
internet content.
Step four is the
internet's best friend.
And five, it's remember steps.
That's a lot to remember.
We know that.
So we wanted to give you a
little device to remember this.
So we pulled out the letters
you need to know, so right here.
That will identify every step
pretty easily in your mind.
Put them together.
GHRA LARINDYNGS.
Super easy.
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
That may not look
like-- if you wanted
to make it even easier,
let's mix those up into
something even easier.
Garry Shandling.
BEN BERKLEY: And when you
think Garry Shandling--
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
What do you think of?
Content going viral.
BEN BERKLEY: Got it.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: It's easy.
BEN BERKLEY: That's it.
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
It's real easy.
BEN BERKLEY: Yeah.
Now you can do--
JERMAINE AFFONSO: It.
BEN BERKLEY: You did it.
You got it.
Viral content.
You'd know how to make.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: You
know how to do it.
So give it up for yourselves.
BEN BERKLEY: Yeah, let's--
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Give
it up for yourself.
You know what else?
BEN BERKLEY: For viral content.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Give
it up for viral content.
Because here's the
thing, at ClickHole
we believe, at the
end of the day,
that all content
deserves to go viral.
All of it.
BEN BERKLEY: Every single one.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Every
single piece of content.
Let's hear it.
Let's all say it together.
Come on.
EVERYONE: All content
deserves to go viral.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Again.
EVERYONE: All the content
deserves to go viral.
BEN BERKLEY: We're not talking
tens of thousands of pages.
We're talking millions.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Every piece
of content deserves to go viral.
BEN BERKLEY: All of it.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Here's
the thing, though.
Unfortunately--
what just happened?
The thing is not all
content is able to go viral.
In fact, every day
many pieces of content
fail to go viral for one reason
or another, many of them,
very young.
BEN BERKLEY: So sad.
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
And we've actually
put together a little
tribute to the content
we've lost, content
that didn't go viral.
Let's do that right now.
BEN BERKLEY: Yes.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Well, I
think it's a good time to--
BEN BERKLEY: Check in.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Check in
on some of your feedback.
See what-- gotten
some e-mails, maybe.
BEN BERKLEY: Let's see
what we've got here.
Let's pop out of
this for a second.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Excuse us.
BEN BERKLEY: Oh my goodness.
We've got some e-mails here.
This is fantastic.
OK.
Let's just see what we got.
Let's start at the bottom, just
kind of read through these.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Yeah,
let's see what's going one.
BEN BERKLEY: Is this too
[INAUDIBLE] for you guys?
The thing.
How did I-- Let's do that.
Cheated a little bit.
OK.
So this one's from
William Fivis.
"Dear ClickHole, I
have one question
about your talk
at Google so far,
which is why aren't there
more pictures of sand?
I was hoping to see at
least some pictures of sand.
And so far I haven't seen any.
Help me."
JERMAINE AFFONSO: OK.
BEN BERKLEY: Fair enough.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: I
bet we can incorporate
some pictures of sand.
BEN BERKLEY: Very good feedback.
OK.
Let's go back to the old inbox.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Jane Henley.
What is this?
"Dear Phil, I don't know
how to tell you this,
but I don't love you anymore.
I've had feelings for
your brother, Dave,
since I met him on
our wedding night.
I can't keep
ignoring my feelings.
We're in love, Phil.
And I'm leaving you.
Sincerely, Jane."
BEN BERKLEY: She found love.
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
She fell in love.
BEN BERKLEY: Which is great.
OK, good for her.
Oh, what is this guy?
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Who is this?
Steven Spielberg.
BEN BERKLEY: Oh, my god.
OK.
"Dear ClickHole,
This talk is bad.
The only thing worse than
this talk is working the child
actors, because they're
living scum who cannot act.
I'll never watch another
ClickHole talk again.
And more importantly, I'll never
work with another child actor
again.
Sincerely, Steven Spielberg."
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
Steven Spielberg, man.
BEN BERKLEY: Living legend.
That's huge.
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
He's watching us.
BEN BERKLEY: OK.
Oh this doesn't look good.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: It's
from a doctor, no?
"Dear Phil, We received
the results of your biopsy.
And we are sorry to report
that you have cancer.
It's inoperable.
And we believe at the rate
it's currently spreading,
you have approximately
three months to live.
I realize it's highly
unorthodox to e-mail
a patient the results
of their biopsies,
but we're making an exception
to the rule this time,
because your cancer
is really bad.
In fact, it's hard to
call what you have cancer,
because it's so, so much worse.
Like it's really awful.
A nurse cried when
she saw your biopsy.
She had to take the
rest of the day off.
What I'm saying,
Phil, is that they're
going to name a state after you,
because your cancer is so bad.
Jesus."
Anyway--
BEN BERKLEY: Oh boy.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Dr.
Henry Billingsley.
BEN BERKLEY: Really
nice guy, though.
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
Seems like a nice man.
BEN BERKLEY: OK, let's just
keep seeing what else we got.
This looks positive.
"Dear ClickHole,
I haven't been
watching your talk.
I just wanted to let you know
I'm a huge fan of e-mails.
Can't get enough e-mails.
Love them.
Marsha Jennings"
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
I also like emails.
BEN BERKLEY: I love them.
They're great.
Good.
We're doing well.
Got a lot of good feedback.
Ah, email confusion.
Oh.
OK.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: "Dear
ClickHole, My name
is Phillip Henley.
I recently discovered
that your email address,
ClickHoleGoogleT
alkFeedback@yahoo.com,
is very similar to my email
address, ClickHoleGoogleT
alkFeedback2@yahoo.com.
And that you may be
getting some of my mail.
Seems like a very easy mix up.
Anyway, if you're getting
my emails, let me know."
Oh, we can send them over.
BEN BERKLEY: That's great.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Seems
like such a nice guy.
You should give him thanks.
BEN BERKLEY: Thanks.
That's sweet.
OK.
I don't know.
I guess we can see-- people
think this is not real.
You are a hand idiot.
Sure.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: I love
all of this feedback.
People are so nice.
BEN BERKLEY: Oh that's
actually-- that's not true.
Yahoo email works a lot better
on our preferred browser,
Safari.
What else?
Let me ask.
Oh, that's not good.
Under the podium.
It looks pretty bolted down.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Yeah.
Sorry, Tyler.
I'm so sorry.
BEN BERKLEY: Thanks for
coming, though, Tyler.
Thank you for coming.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: It's
really nice to have you here.
BEN BERKLEY: OK.
Scares to go on the internet.
I don't like this one.
No.
I don't know what it said.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: That's
the same one, right?
BEN BERKLEY: Yeah, I just was
actually reading it this time.
I don't know.
This is sad.
This one's just sad.
Come on, Derek.
We don't need this, Derek.
Oh.
This is great.
That's actual feedback.
That's really nice.
Cool.
Well, I feel like
we can incorporate
some of this going forward.
This is actually really helpful.
Very, very helpful for us.
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
That we're an idiot.
BEN BERKLEY: Yeah,
we are and idiot.
That's fine.
All right.
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
I think we want
to go a little bit into
the next section of this,
and take you guys sort of
actually behind the scenes
of ClickHole and what we do
and our writing process and all
that stuff.
BEN BERKLEY: So let's
talk about how it's made.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: How it's made.
BEN BERKLEY: Well, we can
talk about just the numbers
of people behind it, such
as eight full time writers
and editors.
We also have additional support
staff, freelance writers,
graphics, video,
people are incredible.
It's a very, very
collaborative process.
A lot of hands touch it.
It's not something
where-- there is
a reason there aren't by
lines on the site, which
is because it is
that group effort.
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
It's very cooperative.
BEN BERKLEY: And these
are these people.
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
Yeah, that's the group.
And our new ClickHole hoodies
that are not available
anywhere.
BEN BERKLEY: Don't ask.
Don't ask.
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
They're pretty sweet.
BEN BERKLEY: Yeah.
So everything starts
with a headline, which--
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
Yeah, so it's like it's
kind of similar to the
onion process, which
is that every joke that you
see on ClickHole, that starts
with the headline
of the article,
it always pitched in
the headline form.
So you see "Amazing!
This school has two proms."
That's kind of what's
written on the page,
and we kind of talk about
it and we go from there.
Basically every writer goes
home and comes up with anywhere
between 10 to 20 headlines,
come in with that,
they email them in, we put them
on a list, and we sit around,
kind of at this table, and talk
through the-- people will sort
of pitch an idea out loud, and
either it's met with resounding
silence and we all move
on, or we like it and laugh
and, as we're doing
in this lovely image--
BEN BERKLEY: Two
people are laughing.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Everyone
else is dead silent.
And then it goes in.
It goes into the site.
We brainstorm it.
We brainstorm the idea,
and then one writer
takes it home and actually
puts it all together
and writes the piece.
BEN BERKLEY: Right.
And one thing that we should
talk about next is volume.
So there are about 850 to a
1,000 ideas pitched every week,
which ultimately maybe 50 or
so those end up going anywhere.
So it's frustrating.
That's kind of the magic
of ClickHole, which
is stolen from the magic
of the onion, which that
is similar percentages at
work there, where you're just
pitching so many things and
then the quality standard is so
high that things
are being, jokes
are being knocked
down for reasons
that we can talk about later on.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Yeah,
we'll talk about it later.
But sometimes it's
very simple things,
like it feels too similar to
something we've done before,
a lot of times it
feels too similar
that someone has read on
Twitter, or something else.
And then we kind of just want it
to feel original, fresh, and as
much from our own voice, and
unique, and the right level
of funny, to be exact.
BEN BERKLEY: A lot
of really funny stuff
doesn't make it, which we can
show you some of that in a bit.
So talking about graphics.
I think this is something
that is underrated
on this site, which is we have
very talented graphic artist
who build the world for us.
I mean, the things they
can do on Photoshop,
I don't know how they're real.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Yeah, we ask
them to do some insane stuff
and they always deliver
in amazing ways.
BEN BERKLEY: Just taking
so many different elements
putting them together.
So we just have a
couple of before
and afters to show
off here for them.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: This
is the kindest man alive.
Jon Hamm guarded this
nest of orphaned snake
eggs for three months.
Part of our Jon Hamm
character when he
does good things for animals.
So this is the first one,
at the beginning of it.
BEN BERKLEY: So this
is shot in our office,
in the kitchen of our office.
And then all of a sudden,
that turns into that guy.
Taking another
look, we have meet
the puppetteer behind
blue ivy, which is funny.
So this was just
shot in our studio.
And then that all of a sudden
becomes that right there.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: This Make
a Wish kid couldn't decide
what he wanted, so they slid
him along a deli counter
like a sandwich.
The headline.
Let's look at the image.
This is Erik, one of our
graphics people with an actor.
And then this was shot
also in our kitchen.
And that became,
yeah, there you go.
BEN BERKLEY: Yep.
So another wonderful thing
about working where we work
is the response to
everything we do.
It's fun.
It's crazy.
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
Like the onion,
like the satirical
thing, sometimes people
take things seriously.
They take it real.
That's never the intention.
The intention is always
that it's a joke.
But it happens.
And people respond
in fantastic ways.
So here are some
of the best ones.
BEN BERKLEY: Yeah.
So here's a blog that
ran on ClickHole.
The ability to play as Bowser
has made our society more evil.
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
So this entire blog
was just this guy
basically going insane,
like as soon as
Mario Kart came out
and people could play as
Bowser, society fell apart.
The option to select the
unscrupulous Wario is vulgar,
but allowing gamers, often young
gamers, to select the wanton,
lascivious Koopa King
is beyond barbarous.
It's outright criminal.
So someone took this seriously.
BEN BERKLEY: They
took it so seriously.
I have the e-mail right
here, which is maybe
the angriest e-mail I've ever
seen working at The Onion,
about Bowser, so
that's surprising.
And it's dreadfully long, so
we edited it a little bit,
but you'll get the gist.
"When I was shown this
article about how Bowser
has been the problem
of our society
ever since he has
appeared in Mario Kart,
I was appalled by the very
notion of this bullcrap.
To blame one Nintendo
villain for being
playable in a game
of racing and say
he's the reason everything
bad is happening in the world
offends me.
People from the so-called
Bowser generation
said how it's affected them in
the blog, saying things like,
Bowser taught me that good is
stupid and that evil is good.
Or they said, my
little brother always
picks Bowser when we play Smash.
Something has died
inside him since that.
Or even, 9/11 happened
just nine years later.
Seriously?
What the hell?
This is not something
to say at all.
How in the hell does
a villain character
get blamed for a
terrorist attack?
There are worse characters than
Bowser in the Nintendo company,
and even worse outside Nintendo.
To pin it on one
character is unacceptable.
There have also
been plenty of games
where Bowser was a good
guy or worked with Mario
to defeat a greater enemy.
He's not all bad.
But he isn't good either.
But this doesn't
mean he's bad enough
to wreak havoc by corrupting
children born after the game's
release.
He's a great character who
is loved by many people,
and just get some kid would
play as him, doesn't he's
going to blow up a building
when he grows up, doesn't mean
he's going to go mental and
set random civilians on fire,
it's just a kid playing a game.
So that's why I'm not
asking, but demanding,
this article be removed
from the face of the planet
to prevent any uprising
this blogger creates
from his poorly written
story full of lies, possibly
hate, and useless information.
Thank you for your time.
And I will be
watching for that post
to be erased from mankind."
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
Very passionate.
BEN BERKLEY: Very
passionate about Bowser.
Never saw that coming.
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
This is another one.
Yeah, this is five tragedies.
AUDIENCE: Classic.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Yeah, this
was a very popular article,
and it had things like, in
the middle of Happy Gilmore,
Adam Sandler turned right to
the camera, and then said,
Princess Diana will die in three
years, and things like that.
And it went online, people
thought it was a joke,
it was popular.
But then some people
took it seriously.
And some people in
our comment section
would even say things like, I
actually remember that moment
from Billy Madison.
I totally remember that, when
it said the BP oil spill will
happen in five years.
But what's also interesting
is that this article started
gaining traction among white
supremacists, who posted it
on their forums evidence
for why the Jews were
evil and magic, because they
could predict future tragedies.
And then if you look at
the form, it would go down
and everyone would be
like, yeah, I knew it.
I knew it.
I knew that Jew-- and
then just went down.
And then eventually,
one person, sort
of a level-headed white
supremacist, came into the fray
and was like, guys,
guys, ClickHole
is a satire site made by
people who made The Onion.
The Jews are evil, but not
because-- they're not magic.
This is a joke.
That's what happened.
This one.
BEN BERKLEY: '90s kids rejoice.
The spider eggs they used
to fill Beanie Babies
are finally hatching.
So this ClickHole's-- this
is a classic for us already.
It's been our most viewed story.
It's a lot of fun.
It's a very fun take on, a
very twisted take on nostalgia
and how that's played
out in the world.
The feedback on this
may be a little sad.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Yeah, so we
got a call at our front desk
from an older woman,
presumably, who
was calling about her
son's Beanie Babies
and how she'd taken
them and wrapped them
all up in duct tape
and then she was
calling to find out
what else could she
do to prevent the
eggs from hatching?
She was desperate
to find out what
the next steps that she could
take, which was really sad.
BEN BERKLEY: But very
funny and great for us.
So another one was this
campaign that happened with us.
It was #StandForManny--
or #StandWithManny.
I can't even read.
That's not good.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Yes, so
this was a little bit more
of a social media thing.
It wasn't part of
a planned article.
We have a really great
social media guy, Dan,
who works on all of
our social media,
he engages with the
audience, basically,
and always is in the
comment section going
back and forth with people.
And in this case, he's happened
to see someone tweet, just
a kid tweeted, this kind
of interesting thing.
"Fuck the school district
blocked ClickHole
and now I have nothing
to do in yearbook."
And so he saw that and
was like, what if we
responded to this in a fun way?
And so we did.
This guy actually changed
his Twitter handle,
which is going to be
a little confusing.
This is what his original.
@mannyhodkin we will
not be silenced.
#StandWithManny.
So we tweeted that,
and it started
gaining all this traction
amongst our fans.
People were tweeting at him,
tweeting at other people
to support #StandWithManny,
and someone
tweeted Barack Obama
should announce that he
supports #StandWithManny.
I told everyone that if he
took God out of the schools,
ClickHole would be next.
What happened to
the First Amendment?
So this went on for
an entire afternoon.
It was kind of
just a fun example
of a very like impromptu thing
that kind of happened out
of nowhere, like not even
planned in our writer's room
or anything.
It was just like a
really cool and fun way
to engage with our audience.
BEN BERKLEY: Yes.
Let's move on to some favorites,
personal favorites for us,
which is a very hard task.
And we love them all.
So this is mine to start.
Youngest child ever?
Jonas just three years old.
I just love how ClickHoles,
they don't understand the world.
It's just like a complete
lack of understanding
of what the world is and
how it actually functions.
And it's delightful.
And then this.
Share if you agree that
the ocean needs more places
for this guy to sit down.
I just got to
support the whales.
And then literally amazing, this
incredible dad loved his family
so much, he got eye
enlargement surgery
so he could look at them more.
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
That's quite the image.
BEN BERKLEY: It's so
twisted, but so beautiful.
At the same time.
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
So excited about it.
BEN BERKLEY: Jermaine,
your favorites.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Yeah.
So I love this quiz.
Someone mentioned it earlier.
Which one of my
garbage sons are you?
Which is really fun.
And it's really
hard to articulate
why this is so great, unless
you've played through the quiz.
So you should really do that.
It's great.
Disgusting ISIS just
released a two-star review
of "In the Aeroplane
Over the Sea."
I also love this.
This is also like our
continuing ISIS character,
where they continually
try to take down America
and increasingly,
in the same ways,
they recently put
up with the Pentagon
on eBay earlier this week.
Those bastards at ISIS.
BEN BERKLEY: Monsters.
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
This is one I love.
Oh, also, I put on a
fat suit to understand
what it's like to be your mom.
I wanted to know what
it felt like when
your mom put on a raincoat
and went outside and everyone
yelled taxi.
I love this one.
It's really a great way to
get the your mom joke back
in the site in a fun
and interesting way.
BEN BERKLEY: It's time.
It needs to get back.
All right, we're just
going to talk very briefly
about the writers'
room, which we'll
do a Q and A in just a minute.
And we can talk more
about that if you
have some more specific
questions, but just
kind of talking about how
certain things can come and go
in that room.
So we're going to
talk just a very,
very-- like if you wonder
where we get ideas,
this is going to be a very,
very underwhelming story
potentially.
But there is this video.
Whoa, one door, two people.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Which is
basically exactly what it is.
It's a door opens, two
people come out of it,
inspiring music
swells and plays.
But the way this happened was
we were in our writer's room,
literally about to start
a meeting, and then
Ben and our editorial
assistant Fran,
they both just walked
into a door together.
Like he walked in and then
she walked in right after.
And someone just said,
whoa, one door, two people.
And we were like, yes, yes.
We're going to put
it on the site.
Then two weeks later,
that was a video.
BEN BERKLEY: Inspiring stuff.
And then there's this headline.
This sting ray misbehaved,
so we dropped it
through a paper shredder.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: So
people really love
this idea in our writer's room.
And I would say,
on average, I think
if people really
like an idea, it's
brainstormed maybe for, I don't
know, two to five minutes.
If it's something we're excited
about, then we put it online.
We sat around talking
about this for 30 minutes.
I swear to God.
And the brainstorms just got
increasingly more insane.
And we always have someone
typing at all times,
getting all these notes down.
We have a little excerpt
from some of this.
He stung one of our friends.
What were we supposed to do?
What a jackass.
It just went on for a long time.
BEN BERKLEY: If
stingrays aren't supposed
to go in paper shredders, then
how come they slide right down?
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
You can't spank him.
Their butt is a weapon.
You can only put him
through a shredder.
So this went on for 30 minutes.
I think at the end of it
all, we ended up deciding,
you know what?
This is really better
as a one liner.
We don't really need an article.
So it went on this section
of the site called next week
on ClickHole, which is
just pure one liners that
never have articles with them.
BEN BERKLEY: So
that was a waste,
except for in this
moment where you
get to know that this happened.
So now we're going to
actually talk about what
ClickHole has taught us.
We've been at this now
for-- we launched last June.
So we have a little bit
of time under our belts
and have just kind
of seen the way
the world has taken this
site, and just kind of-- we're
reflecting.
It's a beautiful moment for us.
So the first lesson is just
that the internet is weird.
Obviously a very good
lesson to take away.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Yeah.
And I think to us
what that means
is that the internet
is very absurd.
Well, the Internet is
like the weirdest thing.
It exists, and so we all use it
all the time, which is strange.
But the big thing
is that I think
one of the big concerns
when we were starting
the site both internally
and externally
is how are you going to make
fun of something that is already
a self parody of itself
and things that are already
so weird, how are
you going to do it?
And I think with
the way we responded
to that was by honing in on this
very weird and surreal voice,
very specific tone,
and kind of trying
to out weird the internet
as much as possible.
BEN BERKLEY: Which is hard.
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
Which is really hard,
and it's a continuing process.
But I think that's kind of
one of our big takeaways.
BEN BERKLEY: Yeah, absolutely.
Another one is that the
internet is also good.
I think that was something where
we came into this not really
sure what would happen
when you interact
with the internet in
any way, because we've
both-- before
ClickHole happened,
we were just working
at The Onion.
And The Onion is this monolith.
The character of The Onion is
to never acknowledge our readers
in any positive way.
And so for us, it was OK.
Now we have to do a
site where you probably
need to interact with people.
And then what you know
about the internet
is that the commenting
society is not a society.
It's anarchy.
And then we did ClickHole.
And we were surprised
that it's actually great.
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
We really cool fans
that support jokes and don't
make it about themselves,
make it about the greater
thing, the greater joke,
and so we had
here's to you, which
was a very popular article.
Basically we said
this is the most
viral image on the internet.
We have a winner.
It's most viral thing.
It's everywhere.
Everyone is sharing it.
And so our fans
seemingly went out
of their way to try and
actually make it the most shared
image on the internet.
Like every ClickHole
article will
have, in the Facebook
comments, will
have some iteration
of that here's to you
guy and some weird things
that happened to him.
Then in sort of a
different [? way ?],
we recently did
a campaign, let's
give Bob Dylan a nice
bed, which the idea
was to do a crowdfunding thing.
And you know Bob Dylan
is a music legend.
He's given us so many things.
So we thought we ought
to give something back.
And what better than
a Sleep Number bed?
So we raised-- what
was it? $1,500?
More than that?
To buy him a bed.
Everyone chipped in.
And we had like a
reward system for people
who gave a certain amount.
And we bought the bed,
we confirmed delivery
to Columbia Records, we haven't
confirmed that he has it.
BEN BERKLEY: But we know.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
BEN BERKLEY: There's no other
way that this could be going.
A third lesson is that
stupid is also good.
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
These are two things.
This one we did right
when the site launched.
I believed the headline was,
we left a stick of butter
out in room temperature
and you won't
believe what happens next.
Then you've got a five hour
video of butter melting.
Then on top of that, we
did it again a year later.
We left a stick of butter
out at room temperature,
you won't believe what happens
next, patriotic edition.
Flag in the thing.
So we like stupid things.
BEN BERKLEY: Yeah,
and so I kind of
like to think of it that
we have the only work
environment, maybe in the
world, where you can directly
say to your coworkers when
they present an idea to you,
that is so dumb, and that
is a genuine compliment.
That's like the best
thing you can say to them.
So that's weird.
Another lesson is, oh, my god.
William.
William wanted those
pictures of sand.
See, we listened to
your feedback, people.
Come on.
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
Incorporate that.
BEN BERKLEY: Look at that.
There's another one.
That's pretty good.
You're welcome, William.
Lesson four is that
everything is amazing.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Yeah.
And I think that's a big
part of ClickHole's voice
is that we are excited
constantly about everything
in the world ever.
It doesn't matter
if it's good or bad.
Whatever it is ClickHole
will say it's amazing,
it's wow, great, cool.
And I think that's a parody
of like [INAUDIBLE] culture.
Everything that you see on the
internet is the biggest thing.
It is the best thing.
This is the thing.
You've got to click on this.
And so that's kind of the
voice that we're going for.
And I think it's reflected
not just in our headlines,
but in the videos and
articles we make ourselves.
Like this was Hamm
goes up an escalator.
The headline was, yes,
Hamm goes up an escalator.
And the way it's shot is
inspiring and beautifully
shows that Hamm
going up the thing.
And there's a
pause in the music.
And it really
influences every aspect
of the site, that
enthusiasm and positivity.
BEN BERKLEY: Yeah, and
comedically also sets it
aside a little bit.
Because most comedy
is coming from a place
that's a little bit less happy.
So it's one of the
few entities out there
that's really doing
something where
it's this hyperpositive comedy.
So that's kind of been
really nice to watch,
and also very nice
for the people who've
worked on The
Onion who are like,
oh, we can do something
a little bit more happy.
Which is great.
And then we have other
things, which is you guys.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Yes.
So we want to open up for Q and
A and just get any questions.
BEN BERKLEY: Oh,
nobody's brave enough.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Hey, would you
say that this audience
is a representative sample
of your demographic?
BEN BERKLEY: We haven't
looked at you guys once.
Probably.
AUDIENCE: Probably?
OK.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: I think so.
People who work at Google.
BEN BERKLEY: Yeah,
I think exclusively
people who work at
Google are on our site.
And that's fine, because
there are so many of you.
AUDIENCE: For the people
on VC, the question
is have any celebrities
taken the quotes
that you publish on social media
seriously attributed to them?
BEN BERKLEY: I forgot there
are other people watching us.
[INAUDIBLE]
BEN BERKLEY: I don't like that.
That's not good.
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
Yeah, actually.
BEN BERKLEY: Yeah.
Oh, Russell Crowe.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Russell
Crowe got really upset.
I wish I remembered what
we even said about him.
BEN BERKLEY: Yeah, I
called rubbish though.
AUDIENCE: Anderson Cooper?
BEN BERKLEY:
Anderson Cooper, yes.
Anderson Cooper.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Oh yeah,
Anderson Cooper got confused.
We attributed him
to speaking at-- we
said that he gave a speech
at New York University,
and then he said like,
this really weird thing
about golfing to students, and
then hitting a hole in one.
And then he was like, where
did you guys get this from?
I didn't speak at NYU.
We've had a couple
of moments like that.
AUDIENCE: Question is what's
the process for developing
quote like ClickVentures?
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Oh man,
those take a really long time.
Basically what happens is
a writer is set aside, goes
goes away for what?
Like a week?
And just sort of puts
one of them together.
They're all pitched in the
room like the headlines,
so we had like one about
winning a cooking competition.
And we all liked the idea.
We're like, OK, cool.
And then the writer just kind
of goes off, makes half of it,
kind of starts
putting it together,
and then they come in
halfway through the week,
and check in with us, and
we all kind of look at it,
play through it,
offer suggestions.
It's cool because because
it's so elaborate and so hard
to put together, the
writers like really
get a full say in what it is and
not much editing happens to it,
not much else is touched, so
it's kind of the writer owns--
BEN BERKLEY: Do we need to
clarify what ClickVentures
are by the way?
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Maybe.
BEN BERKLEY: Maybe.
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
ClickVentures are--
we have this new feature,
which is just like a choose
your own adventure game
that you can sort of play
through various scenarios.
Our first one was, can
you survive a bear attack?
And so you're
presented with that.
And you have to go through it.
BEN BERKLEY: The answer
is almost entirely no.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Most
of the time it's no.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So instead of trying
to out BuzzFeed BuzzFeed, which
when I heard there is
like going to be a satire
site of ClickBait, I was like,
how could they satire it?
You went with the more
surreal direction.
What do you see as like, apart
from surrealism, the sort
[INAUDIBLE] stuff,
what is the strength
and voice of CllickHole?
And what if BuzzFeed
starts going surreal?
BEN BERKLEY: I mean, well, I
would just say for one thing,
we're never really that
concerned about other sites.
I think once we launched it,
we were moored by ClickBait
and that was a good
entry point for us.
And then from there,
it just turned
into-- anything that's
on the internet, that's
our playground.
Go for it.
Let's make the best
comedy site that there is.
So we're not necessarily
looking at if they do,
which I guess they've
started doing more comedy.
OK.
That's fine.
And then, voice?
Rank the voice?
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Yeah, I mean
I think it's just so specific
and it's a specific
voice that we have that
even if someone else
tried to be absurd--
and there are lots on the
internet that are absurd.
I just think that
our way of doing it
is so specific that there's kind
of room for everyone, in a way.
And I think people
like our stuff,
and will keep coming
in and checking
in on our voice and our
specific absurdities
and our little obsessions.
BEN BERKLEY: And to clarify,
also just our big concern
at the outset was, how do
you satirize a moving target?
Because everything
that new media--
I hate that phrase--
if that's what
we're parodying with
ClickHole, like that's
changing all the time.
So we wanted to make sure
it was flexible enough
where we do actually sit down.
And you know,
yesterday we were just
talking like, OK, what's next?
And that's we
don't have answers.
But I think that's kind of
the challenge of ClickHole
is that it's always
going to need
to be changing over the years.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: And what's
really cool about-- just
to tie this in really fast
to the ClickVenture thing
is that ClickVentures for us,
the choose your own adventure
things.
They don't really
exist elsewhere.
And so when we
first launched, we
did lists, which
are online, quizzes,
which are online, articles,
which obviously exist,
and then we kind of grew
into this other thing, which
wasn't parodying anything.
It was just getting
the voice that we
established through our
parody into this new form.
And so in that way, I think
we can keep doing that
and keep branching
out and growing
the legs of the monster kind
of in new and exciting ways.
AUDIENCE: Question
is about sponsored
content and how the
sponsorships come into place.
BEN BERKLEY: I mean,
that's something where
specifically us.
We get to approached
by our business staff,
so the exact mechanics
of that can be hazy.
I mean, they send out
requests for proposals
to every site that exists
that has certain traffic
benchmarks and all
of that and has
the right demographic
and all that,
so I think we get a
lot of different things
from a lot of different
companies coming through always
looking to do this and that.
And [? Ford ?] worked for us.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: I wish the
answer to that was cooler.
BEN BERKLEY: Yeah,
that would be great.
I'm so sorry.
AUDIENCE: Question is are
there any off limits topics?
JERMAINE AFFONSO: I think
coming from The Onion,
we've learned that you can
make fun of any subject.
It's all about picking
the right target.
And if you're picking the right
target, anything can happen.
You can make fun of any subject.
And in fact, you should make
fun of anything and everything.
As long as it's always
about punching up and not
punching down.
You never want to make
fun of the victim.
And that's really just
a big onion lesson
that we've carried
through to ClickHole.
So I would say no overall.
If anything, subjects
tend to be more avoided
because they're like, is
this going to be too hacky?
Is everyone kind of just
making this joke on Twitter?
If we can't find a
unique enough take on it.
But never because of the
dangerous or offending people
thing.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I only see your
posts on Facebook,
because I don't have
accounts anywhere else.
Have you guys discovered which
time works best for posting?
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
There are people
that work on that constantly and
are always thinking about it.
I don't know.
I also don't know if there's
really a science to that
still, even right now.
It just seems it really
varies even week from week.
BEN BERKLEY: We're reinventing
the wheel every day,
which is hard.
But yeah, I don't think
there's necessarily any--
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
Yeah, it's really hard
to say when would be the
best time to post something.
I mean, I guess if you
try to think about when
people are at work and--
BEN BERKLEY: Sure.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: And we don't
do anything new at night,
so it's very obvious things
like that, but other than that,
not really.
BEN BERKLEY: It's
also something great
we'll spread, regardless
of when it goes out.
Like you can put something
out on a Friday night,
and if it's hitting the
right marks, then it's gone.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Yeah,
that's actually here.
BEN BERKLEY: Like gone in the
way, like out into the world.
AUDIENCE: Kind of
dovetailing off
that question about what
time is best to post,
when creating headlines, is
that totally a human process?
Or do you guys have
any kind of formulas
for what's going to hit?
JERMAINE AFFONSO: You know--
what were you going to say?
BEN BERKLEY: I was
going to say we always
talk it's impossible to ever
guess what's going to do.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: It's really
hard to tell what will do well.
I mean, I think probably
individually-- the thing
is, when you're
pitching these ideas,
you a lot of times don't even
think about the audience, which
is crazy to think about.
But you're kind of thinking
about the other people
in the room, because you're
pitching towards-- obviously
eventually it'll go
out to the audience.
But before it gets there, it
has to get through eight writers
who have to like your idea.
So I think a lot of
times people really
try to think about the
eight people in the room.
Are they going to like it?
Or how can I make them like it?
They've heard
[? different ?] [? types ?],
so that's kind of
the first barrier.
In terms of what will
be popular and what
will not be popular online,
that's just really hard
to tell.
I mean I feel like recently
we had a headline about Taylor
Swift, about how she was getting
revenge on a fan for a tweet
over like three years, and
then she-- but like that one,
you kind of have an idea.
Like people like to talk about
her, maybe it'd be popular,
but even then,
it's hard to tell.
ALEC FOSTER: Question
is the horror
of the site a conscious part
of the editorial process?
JERMAINE AFFONSO: I don't
know how-- we really
don't sit around, I think, and
dissect things that far down,
but I think that certain
influences are recurring
among certain writer's
work, and then
we just gravitate
towards them naturally.
So it's a very like
natural process,
as opposed to sitting down.
Because I feel
like if we sat down
and we were like, at
the very beginning,
we want to make a site that's
absurd, but also twisted,
and also a little dark, and then
try to put it all in a formula,
I think it would feel
contrived and not good.
I think letting it
evolve naturally,
letting the writer's
sensibilities kind of flow
together, and all blend
into one beautiful thing,
I think that's kind of
what has influenced all
of those elements of the site.
BEN BERKLEY: There's
also going to be
a bit of an inherent darkness
just based on the fact
that this was born out of The
Onion, where that's something
where most of the
staff-- they were either
on staff on The Onion, or
contributing for a while
before.
So there's a draw that draws
a certain sensibility, which
has some of those
elements, and I
think that also kind
of informs the site.
AUDIENCE: Do you guys share
any ideas with The Onion?
Like if you have something
that feels like a good idea,
but just isn't
totally right for--
JERMAINE AFFONSO: I think a
lot of maybe individual writers
will do things.
Like sometimes an Onion-er
will email an idea over to me,
and it's like, yeah,
let's put it on our list.
And I think writers
will pitch things
back and forth like that.
I don't know if there's
been any official like,
oh, this would be
perfect for ClickHole.
BEN BERKLEY: I don't
think it's happened.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Yeah, like
a staff-to-staff turnaround
of an idea, but individuals
will pitch ideas back and forth
all the time for sure.
BEN BERKLEY: Yeah.
Yeah, they're all
pitched as videos.
In fact, we have specific
meetings and other-- Fridays,
for example, that's the day
where you pitch video ideas.
And they can-- has everyone that
started out as like an article
and then went video?
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
Sometimes we'll
have something that is pitched
as a headline, not a video.
Like I think we had beautiful.
This woman took a picture of
herself every day for a week.
BEN BERKLEY: Sure.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: So
it was just like a grid
of photos of a woman.
And then we were
like, you know what
would be amazing is
if on YouTube, people
will put them all together with
a nice music bed underneath?
And so we did that.
We made like a two second video
of her just like-- in one week.
So something like
that will happen.
We'll add an element to a--
we'll add a video element
to articles sometimes.
AUDIENCE: Any anecdotes
about the Pharaohs
of Silicon Valley, which is
the ClickHole Google visit.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: I'm
trying to think if there's
anything fun in the process.
I mean the process was
probably very boring.
It was written by one of our
writers, Adam Levine, who
sat down and put
that thing together.
And it's great.
Yeah, it was very, very simple.
He pitched the idea.
It was like, what if we went
inside Google for a long form
journalism piece?
And he wrote the first
draft and it was great.
I mean, he's a good writer.
So not really much of a funny.
BEN BERKLEY: Most of our
anecdotes are someone sat down,
then it happened.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: Sat
down and typed an article.
Yes.
100%, yes.
Please talk to us after.
Stay around.
BEN BERKLEY: We had
an idea to do this.
That was what we were
going to try to--
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
This presentation
where we try to convince you--
BEN BERKLEY: That was
all about convincing us.
Yeah.
OK.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: That
would be incredible.
BEN BERKLEY: That
would be great.
ALEC FOSTER: The question is
what are some headlines you
like that didn't
make it on the site?
BEN BERKLEY: This is hard.
Well, it's harder for you,
because if you don't like it,
it doesn't go on site.
So I don't know if there
is anything that you
feel like you've missed out on.
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
There've been times
where we've rejected
an idea in the room,
and then later we're just
like let's just put it up,
which is not bad at all.
But I really can't think
of an idea that-- I mean,
if something is
rejected from the room,
it's oftentimes because
it's wrong headed,
and it doesn't feel right.
One idea that I
just thought of-- I
don't even know if I
like it, but it was
a video that was incredible.
Watch this plus-sized model
demolish a Subway sub.
It was like, we knew we
shouldn't do that idea.
So like that's an idea.
I mean, but I don't think
we should have done it.
BEN BERKLEY: I agree.
The question is more if-- it's
just a lot of other sites,
a lot of more potentially
respectable sites
are using more ClickBait
tactics in their headlines,
and if that's just
kind of the way
it's going to be
essentially is the question.
And yeah, probably.
Which we're from
being experts on this.
We're just guys who sit
in a room in Chicago
and make things.
But I think also
what we also see
every day is that everybody
is jockeying for attention.
That's like the only
capital on the internet.
And that's why everything has to
be the most amazing thing that
exists.
And it's more amazing than
the last thing that was also
the most amazing thing.
So I think probably that's
just going to be the way it is.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: It's
fascinating to watch, for sure.
BEN BERKLEY: Yes, it is.
AUDIENCE: How important is
YouTube to your strategy?
And what do you think
YouTube could do better?
BEN BERKLEY: What is that?
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
What did he say?
AUDIENCE: Just in general.
BEN BERKLEY: God, I'm so good.
That's not fair.
It's important.
JERMAINE AFFONSO:
What do you think?
BEN BERKLEY: We use it.
JERMAINE AFFONSO: What do
we use it for, actually?
I guess we put
videos up on YouTube.
People watch them there.
ALEC FOSTER: The question is
where do you get your pitches.
BEN BERKLEY: I mean, I
think we just kind of just
go and try to find them
from some maddening place.
I don't know where
ideas come from.
It's so weird and amorphous.
The thing is I think
a lot of times ideas
will get shot down in the
room because they feel too
like a one for one
parody of something,
which is hard to explain
without examples.
But yeah, I think you can look
online to a certain degree
and look at what
people are doing.
But after a certain
point, it becomes kind
of repetitive and constant.
And if you want your
ideas to stand out
from another writer's
list who's also
drawing from the
same online pool,
you kind of have to just go
into a room in silence and sort
of just think as weird as
possible, which is amazingly
fun and also frustrating.
ALEC FOSTER: All
right, everyone.
We're just about out of time.
So before we leave,
please give a big
thank you to our amazing guests.